-Everybody, Madonna is here!
Madonna!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was trying to think of
a question to ask you
that's never been asked.
-Good luck.
-I know.
How about this one?
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-This might be the best question
I've ever asked.
-Okay.
-Has any review of anything
you've done gotten it right?
Is that a good question?
-I mean, occasionally.
It's rare.
-So they don't, really.
-In the 40 years that I've been
doing what I've been doing --
-40 years?
-40 years. Can you believe it?
-No. That's insane.
-It is. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you know who you are?
Do you even know who you are?
You are Madonna. Oh, my God.
-I still don't even know
who I am.
-Yeah, you really are
unbelievable.
I mean, the first single was
what? "Everybody?"
-Mm-hmm.
-And do you remember
anything about that?
Like, what would you do to --
Do you remember
hearing yourself on the radio,
and going, "Wow"?
-I remember I was living on
the Upper West Side,
on 99th and Riverside Drive,
and was just broke
and wondering if things were
ever going to work out for me.
And I had signed my record deal.
And I was told that they
were going to start
playing my song on the radio,
"Everybody."
-Yeah.
-And then, suddenly,
my roommate had her radio on
down the hall, and I heard it
drifting down the hallway.
And I was like,
"Wait, what is that?
What is that?"
And I ran down the hall,
and she's like,
"They're playing
your song on the radio.
And I just stood there
like, "Wow!
It happened. It works."
It was like magic.
-Yeah.
-It was the most amazing moment.
-Is this going to be in this --
I heard there's a rumor that --
-A visual autobiography?
-Yes, of course.
-Don't call it a biopic.
-But, yeah, -- I would never
call it a biopic.
-How dare you?
-No, how dare you?
I think it's cool.
Once again, no one's done this.
-Well, the reason I'm doing it
is because a bunch of people
have tried to write movies about
me, but they're always men.
Ugh!
-Wait. What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
No.
Men are good.
Some men.
-Some men are good.
-Yeah.
-Men -- "Good men" is pretty
much an oxymoron, but --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Anyways...
No, because people
were writing --
I read Universal was doing a --
Like, they sent me the script
because they wanted my blessing.
And I read it,
and it was the most hideous,
superficial crap I ever read.
And then I found out that
some -- I found out --
I'm not even going to
say his name,
but he's a total misogynist --
was directing.
And I'm thinking,
"Why would these people
make a movie about my life?"
There's nothing true
in the script.
The guy who is making it
has no understanding of women,
no appreciation of women,
no respect for women.
So, like, this happened
a couple of times,
and I had to, like,
call people up,
call up the heads of studios,
call up my agents and
threaten them
and say that I will, like,
stand in front of the building
and make -- and protest
and make everybody's life
a misery if
they go through with it.
And they still did not
take me seriously.
-So, finally, I just threw
down the gauntlet.
Have you ever thrown down
the gauntlet?
-I've thought about it.
-Therein lies the rub.
You have to throw down
the gauntlet.
-"Therein lies the rub."
Yeah, I did.
-You have to do this.
You have to do this.
-Oh, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay? Never mind.
I'll pick it up myself.
-Yeah, exactly.
"I'll pick it up myself."
-Because that's what
you've got to do in life.
You've got to
pick it up yourself.
Anyways, no, I just said,
"You know what?
There's nobody on this planet
that can write or direct
and make a movie about me
better than me."
And that is just the truth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I agree.
I love that you're doing that.
And, honestly, no one has -- -
-Keep talking while
I undo my glove.
-Yeah, no problem. Yeah.
-Say interesting things, please.
-I have an
interesting thing to say.
These are myths and rumors
about you,
and I want to know
if some things
are true and
some things are false.
Do you mind me going through
these and you tell me?
-Go ahead.
-Well, do I believe you?
Will you tell me the truth?
[ Laughs ]
Honestly, I can't even tell you
how nervous I feel right now.
You just -- You do -- You make
me so -- you make me so --
-♪ Good inside ♪
-Yeah, you really do.
Okay.
-Come on, you guys. Like a...
-♪ Virgin ♪
-Oh, my God.
-♪ Touched for the... ♪
-♪ Very first time ♪
-♪ Like a...♪
-♪ Virgin ♪
-♪ When your heart beats ♪
♪ Next to mine ♪
-Come on, now.
That's what -- Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
An impromptu...
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright. Wait, wait, wait!
-Trying to get my --
-Alright, ready?
These are myths
and rumors about you,
and it may or may not be true.
Your first job was at
Dunkin' Donuts
and you were fired.
-Yeah.
It was one of the first jobs
I had working
when I moved to Manhattan.
And I did get fired
because I was
playing with the jelly squirter.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, alright.
-Have you ever seen
a jelly squirter?
-No, no, no, I haven't.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
♪♪
No, stop, stop, stop.
Okay, here we go.
Just stop, stop, stop.
Alright, here we go.
-It's funny how everything
is a sexual innuendo.
-It really is. How about this?
"Vogue" was originally only
going to be a B-side
because it wasn't considered
strong enough
to be released as a single.
-Yeah, it's true.
-What?
But "Vogue" is
the biggest song ever.
It was the B-side?
What was the A-side?
-Well, there's a lot of
unenlightened people
in the world.
-Yeah.
-They can't see into the future.
-Did you write "Jimmy Jimmy"
thinking of me?
-Nope.
-Okay.
-Here's a myth or a rumor.
You turned down
the role of Catwoman
in the film "Batman Returns,"
and the lead in "Showgirls"
you turned down.
Did you ever see those movies?
And what did you think of them?
-I saw them both.
And I was -- I regret that I
turned down Catwoman.
That was pretty fierce.
-Oh, really?
-"Showgirls," no.
But I also turned down the role
in "The Matrix."
Can you believe that?
-You did?
-I wanted to kill myself.
-Oh, stop it. You're Madonna.
-That's like one
the best movies ever made.
-You don't regret anything.
Look at you.
-A teeny, tiny part
of me regrets
that just one moment in my life.
-Madonna, are...
Wow. You're unbelievable.
Why? Why?
But why are you such a
troublemaker?
Why? Just stop.
-Because.
Because artists are just here
to disturb the peace.
-Just stop. Just be good.
-Okay, okay. I'm sorry.
-Behave!
-I will.
-Please behave!
-Okay!
-Madonna, I can't even tell
you -- I really do mean this.
I'm just -- I love you, and I'm
honored to have you here.
And I just love you.
You're one in a million.
You're the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Madonna, "Madame X" is available
on Paramount+ tomorrow.